yes Brian we spoke to quite a few people
coming here to Las Vegas from all around
the country and really all around the
globe you can see how crowded it is
behind me now we are of course the only
country that does celebrate Thanksgiving
but those from other countries say
they're coming here to really get the
entire fun holiday experience
Thanksgiving may be over but the holiday
hustle and bustle is just beginning this
is a fun place it has everything we want
to do so many are taking to the skies to
visit family others aren't using the
time to have a little fun we forgot it
was Thanksgiving yes and then we said oh
my God this is Black Friday
touchdown at Harry reard International
Friday from Calgary in Alberta Canada
since they already celebrated
Thanksgiving last month she's taking the
opportunity this weekend to soak up
everything Las Vegas has to offer and we
were actually Googling to see how late
the shops are open
AAA ranked our city as the third most
popular destination to visit this
holiday weekend behind Disney World and
Disneyland around 55 million Americans
are scheduled to travel to and from
their hometowns through Sunday with
about 1 million moving through Harry
Reid International
a lot of those people like Hashem
arriving from across the globe not for
this prominent American beginning of the
season but to kick-start their own
yearly Traditions with a vacation ahead
of the holidays I think the life it's
just exciting and you know it kind of
cuts down on our Long Winter
my travel experts say the rush here in
Las Vegas and really all around the
country should continue through Sunday
and even into Monday so if you are
traveling in the next couple days of
course prepare for that extra traffic
those extra delays and pack some extra
patience reporting live at Harry Reid
International Airport tonight social
Loftus 8 News Now